Cela lui semblait comme de supplier de rester là avec le chapeau.
Et j'ai reconnu sa peur de « Est-ce juste ? » et « Trouve-toi un boulot. »
Et pendant ce temps, mon groupe devient de plus en plus important.
Nous avons signé avec un label important.
Et notre musique est à mi-chemin entre le punk et le cabaret.
Ce n'est pas pour tout le monde.
Eh bien, c'est peut-être pour vous.
Nous signons, et il y a tout ce battage publicitaire pour notre prochain album.
Il sort et se vend environ à 25 000 exemplaires les premières semaines,
et le label considère ça comme un échec.
Et je disais « 25 000, n'est-ce pas beaucoup ? »
Ils disaient: « Non, les ventes sont en baisse. C'est un échec. »
Et ils sont partis.
Au même moment, je signe des autographes et j'embrasse les gens après un concert,
et un mec s'approche de moi
et me tend un billet de 10 dollars,
et il me dit:
« Je suis désolé, j'ai copié votre CD d'un ami. »
(Rires)
« Mais je lis votre blog, je sais que vous détestez votre label.
Je veux juste que vous ayez cet argent. »
Et ça commence à arriver à chaque fois.
Je deviens le chapeau qui suit mes concerts,
mais je dois rester là physiquement et prendre l'aide des gens,
et contrairement au type de ma première partie,
j'ai eu beaucoup de pratique à rester là debout.
Merci.
Et c'est à ce moment que je décide
que je vais juste offrir ma musique gratuitement
en ligne si possible,
c'est comme Metallica ici, Napster, mauvais;
Amanda Palmer par ici, et je vais encourager
le torrenting, le téléchargement, le partage, mais je vais demander de l'aide,
parce que j'ai vu dans les rues que ça marche.
Alors je me suis débarrassée de mon label et pour mon prochain projet
avec mon nouveau groupe, la Grand Theft Orchestra,
je me suis tournée vers le financement participatif,
je suis tombée dans les milliers de connexions que j'avais faites,
et j'ai demandé à ma foule de me rattraper.
Le but était d'avoir 100 000 dollars.
Mes fans m'ont soutenu avec près de 1,2 millions,
ce qui est le plus grand projet de financement participatif musical à ce jour.
(Applaudissements)
Et vous voyez combien de personnes il y a.
Ce sont environ 25 000 personnes.
Et les médias demandaient, « Amanda,
l'industrie de la musique s'écroule et vous encouragez le piratage.
Comment avez-vous fait pour faire payer tous ces gens pour la musique ? »
Et la vraie réponse est que je ne les ai pas obligés. Je le leur ai demandé.
Et par le fait même de demander aux gens,
j'ai créé un lien avec eux,
et en créant un lien avec eux, les gens veulent vous aider.
C'est contre-intuitif pour un grand nombre d'artistes.
Ils ne veulent pas demander.
Mais ce n’est pas facile. Ce n’est pas facile de demander.
C'est un problème pour un grand nombre d'artistes.
Demander vous rend vulnérables.
J'ai reçu beaucoup de critiques en ligne
après le succès de mon projet Kickstarter
pour avoir continué mes folles demandes de contributions,
en particulier pour avoir demandé aux musiciens
qui sont fans s'ils voulaient se joindre à nous sur scène
pour quelques chansons en échange d'amour, de tickets
et de bière, et voici une image de moi
retouchée publiée sur un site web.
Et ça fait très mal, d'une manière que je connais bien.
Les gens qui disent, « Tu ne peux plus
demander ce genre d'aide »,
me rappelle vraiment ceux qui hurlaient depuis leurs voitures, « Trouve-toi un boulot. »
Parce qu'ils n'étaient pas avec nous sur le trottoir,
et ils ne pouvaient pas voir l'échange
qui se passait entre moi et mon public,
un échange qui était très équitable pour nous mais très étrange pour eux.
Voilà, ça ce n'est pas prudent.
Là c'est la fête de célébration de mon projet Kickstarter à Berlin.
A la fin de la soirée, je me suis déshabillée et j'ai laissé tout le monde m'écrire dessus.
Laissez-moi vous dire, si vous voulez faire l'expérience
de la sensation viscérale de faire confiance à des étrangers,
je vous recommande ça,
surtout si ces étrangers sont des allemands bourrés.
C'est une connexion avec les fans au plus haut niveau,
parce que ce que j'étais vraiment en train de dire c'est,
j'ai toute cette confiance en vous.
Devrais-je ? Montrez-moi.
Pendant la plus grande partie de l'histoire humaine
les musiciens, les artistes, ont fait partie de la communauté,
en tant que liens et ouverture, et non pas comme des étoiles intouchables.
La célébrité c'est un grand nombre de personnes qui vous aime de loin,
mais Internet et le contenu
que nous sommes libres d'y partager
nous ramènent en arrière.
Il s'agit de quelques personnes qui vous aiment de près
et de ces personnes qui vous suffisent.
Beaucoup de gens sont désorientés par l'idée
de ne pas avoir une étiquette avec un prix.
Ils voient ça comme un risque imprévisible, mais ce que j'ai fait,
Kickstarter, la rue, sonner à des portes,
je ne vois pas ça comme un risque.
Je vois ça comme de la confiance.
Les outils en ligne pour rendre l'échange
aussi faciles et instinctifs que la rue,
y arrivent.
Mais les outils parfaits ne nous aiderons pas
si nous ne pouvons pas nous confronter
et donner et recevoir sans crainte,
mais surtout,
si nous ne pouvons pas demander sans honte.
J'ai passé ma carrière musicale
à essayer de rencontrer des gens sur Internet
comme je le faisais sur la caisse,
en blogant et en tweetant non pas seulement les dates de ma tournée
et mes nouvelles vidéos mais sur notre travail et notre art
et nos peurs et nos gueules de bois, nos erreurs
et nous nous voyons l'un l'autre.
Et je crois que quand nous nous voyons l'un l'autre,
nous voulons nous aider l'un l'autre.
Je crois que les gens ont été obsédés par la mauvaise question,
qui est, « Comment faire payer les gens pour la musique ? »
Et si nous commencions par nous demander,
« Comment permettre aux gens de payer pour la musique ? »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)